la retirada de raúl castro al frente del
partido comunista de cuba podría parecer
el fin de una era pero en la isla
marcada por su peor crisis económica en
30 años hay poca esperanza de cambio la
escasez generalizada y la falta de
libertades sigue haciendo mella en su
población ya deberían darle paso a nueva
mentalidad no entiendo qué
como que se ha enfrascado mucho en la
situación y pienso que por lo menos lo
que son la parte de los artistas la
parte del humano como tal debería tener
un poco más de libertad entonces con ese
cambio pues que vengan rodeado de un
fuerte hermetismo a puerta cerrada el
viernes inicio el quinquenal congreso
del partido único en cuba el comunista
durante cuatro días se debate el rumbo
político del país de la reunión saldrá
también el próximo dirigente de la
institución el escenario es diferente al
de hace cinco años ahora con una ligera
expansión de internet y las redes
sociales donde los activistas artistas y
disidentes han trasladado su mensaje de
protesta este sábado muchos disidentes
cubanos denunciaron intimidaciones
arrestos e interrogatorios los días
antes del congreso y llamaron uno por
uno a los del 27 ene para amenazarlos
con que si salían de sus casas durante
los días del congreso los iban a llevar
presos por un largo periodo de tiempo la
activista es una de las líderes del
movimiento conformado por artistas que
el pasado 27 de noviembre se reunieron
en la habana para pedir libertades
y acceso de la represión a los
opositores del gobierno algo que se
antoja todavía lejano pese a que castró
de un paso al lado ya que quien tomará
las riendas del país miguel díaz canel
fue designado por el mismo castro la
familia castro sigue estando en los
principales cargos de poder en cuba